over the weekend as you know I was
totally disconnected from news and
politics but some friends of mine we're
talking about Trump and politics and I
was sort of just listening and I started
thinking that I would really respect the
American right and the Trump is right
way more if they stop making excuses for
Donald Trump and specifically I'm
talking about the racism and the
xenophobia and the incompetence and if
they just said you know what yeah it's
true he is all of those things but
here's why I still support him because
what I really am trying to get to here
is that the pro Trump right has kind of
twisted itself into pretzels with these
completely incredible defenses of the
things that Donald Trump has said and
things that Donald Trump has done and
when it was simply bad policy it was a
little bit easier to hide the total
impossibility of their defenses so I'll
give you an example when Donald Trump
passed tax reform with Republicans and
rich people said we like this because
it's going to be great for the economy
that's wrong right like that's
demonstrably wrong but it's at least
true that there are people who think tax
cuts for the rich are good for the
economy so what they mean is these tax
cuts are good for me right but they hide
it as these tax cuts are good for the
country even though that's obviously not
the case okay when Donald Trump a liate
alienates another European ally that's
bad for us but trumpets can argue I
don't care because we've been taken
advantage of by the European Union for
too long I like that we finally have a
president that's going to hold them to
account now I would disagree with that
and lots of them are simply hiding
behind the reality that there's simply
ultra-nationalist anti Europeans but at
least they have some policy explanation
for why they can pretend that Donald
Trump is doing something that makes
sense but now with the last 10 days on
top of the last two years obviously but
the very acute last 10 days of the
xenophobic and racist stuff that Trump
has been ramping up with the defense's
are not even slightly believable Trump's
whole send her back thing
racist because it was the crowd chanting
not Donald Trump himself the entire
attack on four ethnic minority
congresswoman wasn't racist or
xenophobic because Trump simply wants
our country to be good and he's
criticizing anyone who said or did what
they've done because he thinks that it's
the wrong direction for the country
that's all that it is it's not raised to
Sisseton xenophobic these aren't
believable defenses and these aren't
respectable defenses and I am saying I'm
saying I'm actually speaking to the
trumpets right now very often on the
show I say I know that there are
trumpets listening but I'm not speaking
to them there they're off the deep end
I'm speaking to the reasonable people
you know in our audience this is
different okay I'm actually speaking to
the trumpets here I would respect you
way more if you just told the truth okay
and for some of you the truth is you're
also raised as racist and xenophobic and
that's why you like Donald Trump's dog
whistles just come out and say it okay
stop pretending stop couching it all as
merely political rhetoric or strategy or
a healthy version of nationalism or
whatever just tell me I think these
things about minorities and I believe
Donald Trump agrees with me and I like
it and that's why I like him I would
vehemently disagree with you I would
vehemently disagree with what I believe
is a disgusting and self-destructive
view of human relations on our planet
but I would respect you for just telling
it like it is or for other people they
don't actually like the racist and
xenophobic stuff but they're playing
along because they've calculated that
Donald Trump is good for them in some
other way personally like if you're a
rich person who just got this massive
massive tax cut last year because of
Donald Trump just tell me you know what
I am disgusted by what Donald Trump is
saying it is racist it is xenophobic but
I'm going to ignore it because the tax
cut is just so good for me or the trade
stuff happens to be good for my personal
financial interests or whatever I'd
think you were greedy at the expense of
what's best for your country but I would
respect you because you're just telling
me the truth when Trump talks about
caging children
and criminal illegals and Mike Pence
turns his back literally on caged
immigrants don't play the I like this
because I'm for strong borders but I
want legal immigrants here
don't play the I see people as equal
stuff just come out and tell me I like
what Trump is doing with immigrants
because I agree with him about we don't
want people from s whole countries here
I agree with Tucker Carlson that
immigrants are making our country
dirtier just tell me you don't like the
brown people or at least you don't think
they're good for our country I would
respect you way more than when you
pretend that there are concrete and
sensible policy reasons to support this
garbage and I have breaking news for you
increasingly you don't even really have
to hide that that's the case I know
there may be people in the audience who
said you know David's kind of right I do
just not want brown people here or I do
turn the other cheek because this
actually is aligned with my nationalist
beliefs or whatever else Trump's running
on this type of bigotry now so just come
out of the closet okay stop pretending
just admit why it is that you love it
and we can go from there and maybe we
can have some real conversations about
why you hold these views instead of
continuing to tell all of these
completely absurd stories that quite
frankly no one with any common sense
should be falling for in terms of why
you support or defend the actions of
Donald Trump because there are no actual
conservative values that are being
defended with this nonsense
you're either propping up your personal
greed and the sort of what's best for me
point of view or you're propping up your
own xenophobia and racism I just want to
hear you tell it like it is when you
call into my show that as Trump is do
don't play the games of you know Trump
really didn't have a role in the
center-back thing he did try to stop it
right away which is a lie which we'll
deal with later today just say I like it
I do want to send him back those are my
politics and then we can actually talk
like real adults once we establish what
our positions are get away from these
ridiculous unbelievable talking points